qui ment pas
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on ne pourra pas
résumé des épisodes précédents
c'est un mode où il sain qu'on fasse
quoi
le cancer ne frappe que les poumons le
foie la prostate est le cerveau j'aurais
café ressent un mec qui veut transformer
en super esclaves et qui volent ta
chérie
j'en ai joué des rôles mes princesses en
détresse se fait pas voici venu le temps
des super héros
c'est un visage qui m'irait bien entre
les cuisses ier nous voilà à jour
[Musique]
beaucoup
par la bagnole
vous êtes le boss des boss papou la
désinvolture intitule
les cuisses en acier
le joli défi assez
je suis en retard j'étais en train de
rassembler tous butten de la terre pour
le propulser dans l'espace où il pourra
continuer ne rien faire
le mois l'appel de ma vie
c'est quoi ce délire
je m'appelle câble
je viens sur ce gosse
quoi qu'est gosse du pouce ou tu crèves
les enfants nous rendent un peu meilleur
que ce qu'on est
il a besoin de toi ou alors toi tu es
plus futé que j'en nerfs
je ne laisserai pas câble tout est ce qu
a marre mais j'y arriverai pas seul on
n'a qu'un former un groupe de la mort
qui tue et voilà notre groupe sera
progressiste paritaire est connue sous
le nom de
ex farce ça serait sot faire c'est moi
excellente remarque est maintenant
musique donc
parce que faire
why terme
autre mois d'août ils ont bien chauffé
le ralenti
la justice c'est pas toujours propre
et si tu me battre pour le bia
parfois faute salir les doigts
le chignon pour hommes est à cette
génération ce que la coupe mulet était
aux années 80 c'est là que je m'en veux
d'avoir arrêté les études le buzz se
justifie pleinement
beaucoup beaucoup ya plus de raisons de
faire un trois en or est temps d'essayer
on s'arrête aux deux essais une tuerie